absolument media you ever think you were  depressed but you just really needed a  haircut and you got a haircut what was I  worried about I'm freshest I'm super  fresh everything's fine I'm all good I'm  never gonna die I'm gonna live forever  I'm immortal  how can somebody so fresh ever die I'm  everything everything's all right nice  you ever think you would with a haircut  but you just really would depressed I'm  super pear-cut  press everything's depressed I'm gonna  die everything's all right what was a  word about I'm depressed I'm super  depressed  everything's haircut haircut haircut  regular haircut everything's fine I'm  super depressed my hair dress is fine  I'm all good  I'm died I'm raised everything's all  right  [Music]  Hey